a lot of movies that they don't seem to
put across a lot of genuine hope what do
you think is going on there is that
reflecting what our culture is like now
there's not the kind of patriotic movies
that I think you used to get if you look
back to the 2000s particularly you know
America was fighting the war on terror
and so there was a need and a desire for
heroism for for pro-american movies that
doesn't really exist now again I don't
know if it reflects Hollywood's attitude
to All Things sort of American I don't
know if there's weird associations there
where it's like they they feel like it's
dangerous to be be too Pro your own
country I'm not sure what the this the
idea behind it is but there just doesn't
seem to be that optimistic view of like
the whole idea of Western culture I
suppose in movies but they'll repurpose
Fast and Furious 9 and Dumbledore
secrets of Albus or whatever it's called
yeah it's interesting that isn't it